foreign
good morning everyone welcome to this
press conference
here
we will welcome all members of the press
gallery for being here being here today
we'll start
with questions in the room and then
questions online
so if people are online and wish to ask
questions I would ask you to virtually
raise your hand over to you Minister
hello Louie
good morning everyone
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to be here today with my
colleagues doctors Tam and new
today say that together we would like to
update you on a few files related to
health and Public Health in Canada
including
in grievance in principle with provinces
and territories
the Canada Health Act
the Canada dental benefits
and the current state of covet 19.
and postcovid condition also known as
long coveted
first as you know last month prime
minister Trudeau announced the plan
entitled working together to improve
health care for Canadians this plan
invests
almost 200 billion additional dollars
over 10 years
it is a plan co-developed with provinces
and territories based on our shared
Health Care priorities including access
to family doctors
recruitment retention of health care
workers Mental Health
and a world-class data Gathering system
which will let us work together to
protect health and safety
this funding includes a two billion
dollar Top-Up to the Canada Health
transfer to address immediate pressure
on the Health Care system
especially pediatric care and Surgical
backlogs
this additional funding combined with
tax
maneuvers
will
be to drastically increased rate of
federal funding for the Health Care
system
on February 13th provinces and
territories agreed to the plan since
that time my colleague Dominique LeBlanc
and I have met with
provincial premiers and health ministers
as well as premiers and health Ministers
of territories following those meetings
we developed a certain number of
agreements and principles I would like
to thank my provincial and territorial
counterparts for their engagement and
their commitment
to concrete outcomes for healthcare
workers patients and the Canadian public
over the next few weeks we will continue
working together to put the finishing
touches on action plans covering the
first three years of the agreements in
principle
presidential investments in the health
of Canadians our government will always
protect the principles of Medicare and
Shrine in the Canada Health Act
Universal accessible and publicly funded
Healthcare is a point of Pride for
Canadians and protecting it is a
priority for our government
collectively we have made the choice to
leave no one behind and deny no one
necessary care regardless of their
ability to pay
as Healthcare evolves the Canada Health
act must also adapt
to this day there have been three
interpretation letters to that act that
each have served to protect the intent
of our publicly funded Health Care
system
in 1985 shortly following the passage of
the Canada Health act Minister Epp wrote
to his provincial and territorial
counterparts to clarify the ACT criteria
conditions and Regulatory provisions
in 1995 Minister Marlowe wrote to her
counterparts to provide a federal
interpretation of the act as it related
to the issue of facility fees charged
directly to patients receiving services
at private clinics
finally in 2018 Minister Petit Pat
Taylor wrote to her provincial and
territorial colleagues to set out the
diagnostic services policy and the
reimbursement policy strengthening
Canada Health act reporting
it is a responsibility of the Canadian
Health minister to apply deductions to
health transfers to provinces and
territories when you when user fees are
charged to patients for medically
necessary Health Care Services
that is why earlier this week the
Minister of Finance issued letters in
forming provinces and territories of
upcoming Canada Health transfer amounts
and deductions as is the normal process
in advance of the CHT payments the
amounts levied a total of over 82
million dollars in respect of patient
charges levied during 2020 2021 for
medically necessary services that should
be accessible to patients at no cost
these reductions which are five times
higher than the average of previous
years include the first ever deductions
taken under the diagnostic services
policy totaling over 76 million dollars
for patient charges LED aid for
medically necessary Diagnostic Imaging
services
this being said and given rapid and
important changes in healthcare
technology and in the scope of practice
over the last few years it's also
important to make sure that the Canada
Health act continues to be interpreted
to support free and universally
accessible Health Services for medically
necessary care
during the pandemic we have indeed seen
new ways of providing care
while there are many benefits to these
we have also seen an increase in reports
of new patient charges to access insured
health services that would otherwise be
covered if provided in person by a
physician
it is critical that access to medically
necessary Services whether provided in
person or virtually remains based on
medical need and free of charge
I have reminded earlier this week my
colleagues Health Ministers of our
shared responsibility to protect our
Universal publicly funded health care
and that Canadians should always be able
to access medically necessary services
without having to pay out of pocket no
matter where they live in the country or
how care is delivered
Why We should strive to improve health
services for Canadians we must always
ensure that the very core principles of
the Canada Health Act is public nature
universality and accessibility are also
protected and strengthened
that is why I will be Consulting with my
colleagues and will be working together
in the next few weeks to issue a new
interpretation letter in the context of
these changes
one of the ways to strengthen access to
healthcare is through increased access
to dental care to those who don't have
it starting with those who need it most
our children
last fall we introduced the Canada
Dental benefit which allows eligible
families to receive up to 650 tax-free
dollars per year to cover dental
expenses for children under 12.
as of now the benefit has helped more
than 230 000 children get brighter
smiles and healthier teeth
this will make an enormous difference in
the oral health of Canada's children and
it's just the beginning as we work
towards a more comprehensive National
dental program
before I go any further I want to
recognize an important milestone
tomorrow is a national day of observance
for Corvette 19. it was three years ago
on March 11 2020 that the World Health
the World Health Organization declared a
pandemic
none of us will ever forget what
happened in the weeks months and years
as followed
I urge all of us to take a moment to
acknowledge the Canadians who lost their
lives to covid-19 as well as their
families and loved ones
I also Express on everyone's behalf our
gratitude and admiration for an
incredible health care workers who have
sacrificed so much to keep us healthy
and safe during this challenging time
tomorrow is the national day of
observance for covet 19. it was three
years ago on March 11 2020 that the
World Health Organization declared the
kova 19 pandemic
my heart is with the Canadians who lost
their lives to covid-19 as well as their
families and loved ones
I also express my
gratitude and admiration for the
incredible health care workers who have
sacrificed so much to keep us healthy
and safe during this challenging time
many of us have contracted covet 19.
while some of us only felt temporary
minor symptoms
we all know that even minor infections
and reinfections
can have long-term effects including
lasting Health impacts post covid-19
condition also known as long covid
can have
devastating physical psychological and
socioeconomic effects
in summer
Chief science advisor Dr Mona Nemer
established a task force to study post
covid-19 condition and develop guidance
on how to treat it
a summary of the task Force's report and
a set of recommendations were published
in December and the task force published
its entire report yesterday
because science is at the heart of all
of our decision making our government
believes in investing in research
including new research on post-covet
condition
to better understand and support
Canadians living with this condition
our government has invested 20 million
dollars through the Canadian Institutes
of Health research to establish the
pan-canadian
research Network on post covid-19
condition this
Network which is named long covered web
we'll put more than 300 researchers in
touch with Canadians with lived
experience of long coveted this will
help to develop a more precise diagnoses
treatments and Rehabilitation strategies
but it's more the public health agency
of Canada has invested nine million
dollars in Cochrane Canada in the great
centers at McMaster University
to develop clinical practice guidelines
on post covid-19 condition these
guidelines will help Health Care
Professionals to identify
and treat
Canadians living with post-covet 19
condition
I will now yield the floor to doctors
Tam and new thank you
hello everyone three years since the who
director General first characterized
covid-19 as a pandemic
reflecting back on these years we are
reminded of the challenges and
sacrifices we've endured including
grieving so many lives lost due to and
during covid-19 under difficult
circumstances
with a view forward
we are now taking stock of where we are
today including assessing the patterns
and ongoing impact of covid-19 on our
population and Health Systems
the many actions we took together had an
important impact in slowing spread and
reducing severe outcomes of coven 19.
modeling data has indicated that
Canada's experience with covid-19 could
be much worse
however covid-19 has still had an
enormous impact over the past three
years
since January 2020 when the first cases
were reported in Canada
we have experienced multiple waves of
covid-19 resulting in millions of cases
leading to over 51
000 deaths to date
the scale and duration of this
unprecedented Health event
catalyzed a whole of society response
that has tested the resilience and
fortitude of each of us
we are now at a point in Canada where
covid-19 activity has reached a
relatively steady state in recent months
there have been no distinct variant
driven waves such as the well-defined
Alpha Delta and initial Omicron we've
seen previously
likewise over the past six to eight
months covid-19 hospitalizations have
been relatively stable despite the
ongoing spread of Omicron subvariants
ICU Admissions and tasks have also
stabilized
population immunity estimated using
regular antibody studies is currently
high and relatively stable
this level of immunity is also
approaching a steady state due to the
combined effect of our overall High
vaccine uptake and infection acquired
immunity
however as population immunity levels
fluctuate disease activity may also vary
while uncertainty remains about the
seasonal patterns of covid-19 the
current trends suggests we may not see
any major waves in the coming months as
we prepare for a potential fall and
winter surge
together with International Partners we
will also continue to monitor the
situation closely and specifically watch
for the emergence of significantly
immune evasive strains
a steady state does not mean that
covid-19 won't have serious immediate
and lingering impacts covid-19
hospitalizations remain at relatively
steady levels but continue to have a
significant impact on our Health Care
Systems likewise there is a continued
disproportionate impact on older and
immunocompromised populations
we also know that covid-19 infection can
affect chronic disease rates and that
post covid-19 condition or PCC also
known as long covered is also a
significant Public Health Challenge as
underscored by Dr Neymar's recently
published PCC task force report
to address these challenges it will be
important to be vigilant and employ
prudent risk-based use of preventive
measures as we continue to learn about
the longer term impacts and optimal
vaccine strategies and treatments
the public health agency of Canada's
work to support clinical practice
guidelines on PCC and the Canadian
Institutes of Health research's new
funding to establish a pan-canadian post
covid-19 condition research Network
exemplifies some of the tangible steps
being taken towards improved management
and Mitigation Of coven 19's longer term
impacts
going forward we expect ongoing
circulation of SARS cov2 virus but with
the availability of effective preventive
measures and treatments we will be able
to manage covid-19 in a more sustainable
manner
on March the 3rd the national advisory
committee on immunization on Nasi
released covid-19 booster
recommendations for the upcoming spring
Nasi recommends that an additional
booster dose may be offered six or more
months after the last vaccination or
infection to adults at increased risk of
severe illness from covert 19. these
include people aged 80 years or older
adult 65 to 79 years of age particularly
if they do not have a known prior
history of sarsko V2 infection
adult residents of long-term care homes
and other congregate living settings for
seniors
or those were complex medical needs
and those age 18 years and older
considered to be immunocompromised
Massey recommends to use a bivalent
vaccines for booster doses regardless of
risk factors we encourage anyone who has
not yet received their primary covid-19
series or their fog 2022 booster doses
to get these vaccinations
as we adjust our Collective response and
move towards the management of covid-19
as a regularly occurring disease
planning the for the fall must take into
account the potential demands of
covid-19 and other respiratory
infections on our Health Care Systems if
we build on the capacity and knowledge
gained in the past years in protecting
ourselves our health Workforce and each
other we will be well prepared to adapt
our response to Future needs thank you
merci migrich
foreign
first characterized covid-19 as a
pandemic
reflecting back on these years
we are reminded of the challenges and
sacrifices we've endured
including grieving
so many lives lost
due to and during covid-19 under
difficult circumstances
with a view forward we are now taking
stock of where we are today
including assessing the patterns
an ongoing impact of kova 19 on our
population and Health Systems
the many interventions we took together
had an important impact in slowing
spread and reducing severe outcomes of
covet 19.
modeling data
has indicated
that Canada's experience with covid-19
could have been much worse
however covid-19
has still had an enormous impact over
the past three years since January 2020
when the first cases were reported in
Canada we have experienced multiple
waves of covid-19
resulting in millions of cases leading
to over 51 000 deaths to date
the scale and duration of this
unprecedented Health System catalyzed a
whole of society response
that has tested the resilience and
fortitude of each of us
we are now at the point in Canada
where covid-19 activity has reached a
relatively steady state
in recent months there have been no
distinct variant driven waves
such as the
well-defined Alpha Delta and initial
oberkron we've seen previously
likewise
over the past six to eight months
covid-19 hospitalizations have been
relatively stable despite the ongoing
spread
of sub-variants
I see you Admissions and deaths have
also stabilized
population immunity
estimated using regular
antibody studies
is currently high and relatively stable
this level of immunity is also
approaching a steady state
due to the combined effect of our
overall High vaccine uptake and
infection acquired immunity
however as population immunity levels
fluctuate disease activity may also vary
while uncertainty remains about the
seasonal patterns for covet 19. the
current Trend suggests we may not see
any major waves in the coming months
as we prepare for a potential Fallen
winter surge
together with International partners
we will also continue to monitor the
situation closely
and specifically
watch for the emergence
of significantly immune evasive variants
a steady state does not mean that
covid-19 won't have serious immediate
and lingering impacts
covid-19 hospitalizations remain at
relatively steady levels
but continue to have a significant
impact on our Healthcare systems
likewise
there is a continued disproportionate
impact on older and immunocompromised
populations
we also know that covid-19 infection can
affect chronic disease rates and that
post covid-19 condition or long covered
it's also a significant Public Health
Challenge
as underscored
by
Dr Neymar's recently published PCC task
force report
to address these challenges
it will be important to be vigilant and
employ prudent risk-based
anymore use of preventive measures
as we continue to learn about
longer term impacts
and optimal vaccine strategies and
treatments
among the tangible steps being taken
towards improved management and
Mitigation Of covet 19's longer term
impacts
we can note the public health agency of
Canada's work to support clinical
practice guidelines on PCC
and new funding to establish a
pan-canadian post covid-19 condition
research Network
through the
Canadian Institute of Health research
going forward we expect ongoing
circulation of the SARS cov2 virus but
with the availability of
effective preventive measures and
treatments
we will be able to manage covid-19 in a
more sustainable manner on March 3rd the
national advisory committee on
immunization or Nasi
released covid-19 booster
recommendations
for the upcoming spring
Nancy recommends that an additional
booster dose okay that means may be
offered six months or more after the
last vaccination or infection
to adults at an increased risk of severe
illness from covet 19. these include
people aged 80 years or older
adults 65 to 79 years of age
particularly if they do not have a known
prior history of SARS cov2 infection
adult residents of long-term care homes
and other congregate living settings for
seniors or those with complex Medical
Care needs
and those aged 18 years and older
considered to be immunocompromised
Nasi recommends the use of bivalent
vaccines for booster doses
regardless of risk factors we encourage
anyone who has not yet received their
primary covid-19 series
or their fall 2022 booster to get these
vaccinations
as we adjust their Collective response
and move towards the management of
covet 19.
as a regularly occurring disease
your account you can't find positive
signing for the fall must take into
account the potential demands of covet
19.
and other respiratory infections on our
Healthcare systems
if we build on the capacity and
knowledge gained in the past years
in protecting ourselves
our health Workforce
and each other
we will be well prepared to adapt our
response to Future needs
thank you
thank you to the three of you we'll
start with questions here in the room
starting with David from the CBC good
morning everyone cbc's health unit has
done some reporting that shows a
for-profit
surgical clinics are charging Canadians
Minister duclow 20 to 30 000 for hip
replacement surgeries and knee
replacement surgeries they get around
this band by by
um
charging for medically necessary Care by
having the patient travel to different
provinces for this operation so two
questions to you minister duclow is this
in keeping with the Canada Health act
and will you be looking at cracking down
on that
uh thank you and a we are aware of that
be we are preoccupied with that and see
we will address that in in conversations
with my colleagues Health ministers it
it is clearly seen and felt that there
is such a a a loophole in the um in the
ACT which has been there for many many
years uh it's um it's it's impacting the
ability of people to have access to
surgery
it is obviously imposing fees for those
who do have access to a surgery so yes
we are mindful of that then we are going
to work on that
and um to your Mr Khloe again
um why did the Prime Minister say
spending more taxpayer money on
for-profit clinics is innovative
because we're wondering this because
it's been done for years
it doesn't seem to have solved the wait
times and there is some evidence that
shows it increases weights overall and
leads to worst outcomes and some latest
how Canada reports show that Canadians
paid millions of dollars with their
credit cards despite your promises and
loss so I know you've been asked this
before but can you address the prime
minister's comments about Innovative
care when
well the Prime Minister said is that the
Canada Health act as obligations and
some of these obligations are my
obligations and that has kind of Health
Minister have is not my choice it's my
duty that again this morning uh I have
to issue a yearly statement on
deductions that need to apply applied to
transfers to provinces and territories
now these uh these these deductions are
there to protect Canadians that have to
pay for medically necessary services
when it comes to deliver to the delivery
of care through private delivery then we
know that there's been it's been the
private sector delivery of Healthcare in
Canada has a long history
Physicians or self-employed workers they
are privately
operating in in Canada they will be
operating probably four years to come
the same thing for pharmacists and other
health care workers these the way in
which Health Care is is provided in
provinces and territories is the
jurisdiction and responsibility of
provincial Health ministers whether
people pay for those Services is is
something that is part of my
responsibility and as in in that context
that's why I'm announcing this morning
that there will be
increased deductions to uh to transfers
made to provinces and territories and
that there will be a new interpretation
letter issued in a few in a few weeks
from now to deal with the fact that
although we have seen great progress
over the last few years and in part due
to covid-19 on on Virtual care and wage
ways to amend the scope of practice to
make workers more work better together
to give more responsibility to important
Health Care Providers like nurse
practitioners and and physician
assistants although this is all good
news there are risks that we we see when
these beneficial changes to how we use
technology and and workers comes with uh
payments that that people must make when
they are not using the health care
services
in person by a traditional physician and
that's why this interpretation letter
will be built and will be issued in a
few weeks from now
devoir
hello I'd like to
follow up on your announcement about a
letter
you have signed agreements and
principles so new health care agreements
with almost all provinces except Quebec
a few days later
you announced increased deductions to
Health Care transfers
I understand where this is coming from
but the timing of raises eyebrows
what is your response to people who are
asking questions about this series of
events
I have a legal obligation as health
minister
to enforce the Canada Health acts this
isn't a choice I'm making it's part of
my duty it's my yearly responsibility I
need to announce deductions
these deductions recognize the economic
burden
paid by Canadians and quebecers when
they access certain services that should
have been provided for free
a third point
for some time these situations are
becoming increasingly frequent
we have made some good progress
especially during the covid-19 pandemic
towards using more technology and
virtual care
and
spreading out work among other
professionals such as NPS and uh
surgical assistance
this reduces
the burden on doctors as they address
medically necessary provide medically
necessary care
but a new interpretation letter will
come out
soon recognizing these advances while at
the same time noting
that they ought not to
uh
create economic burdens on Canadians who
are already paying for Health Care
through their taxes
I want to talk to you about the timeline
of deductions announced today not not
once in the past
I understand that there are certain
obligations
but this comes just a few days after the
announcement of agreements in principle
are you worried that this timing will
have a negative impact on the ability to
sign an agreement with Quebec
two points first
we always announced deductions in March
towards the end of the fiscal year
this lines up with the time transfers
are provided
as a second point
we are faced with a great opportunity
per the Canada Health Act
Canada provinces can see the deductions
refunded
if there are changes in the Health Care
system so if we look at Quebec
specifically Quebec
could have these deductions refunded at
some point in the next two years
if they
make changes to avoid people paying for
medically necessary care
over the past two years BC has already
made amendments to its Billing System
and
the deductions affecting BC
have been reduced in size
so Quebec can do the same thing
over the next two years
it could change its own Billing System
so that quebecers are not charged for
medically necessary care this will allow
the deductions to be refunded
Michelle Savard
thank you Minister first
why
is Quebec losing 41
a million dollars of Health Care
transfers from 2122 this is roughly
half the transfer that was receiving
are you not giving with one hand to take
him with another
in some provinces like Quebec
Health Canada has observed
that certain diagnoses
were linked to
payments
that are not allowed under the Canada
Health Act
Quebec can undo this situation
by putting in place Solutions like those
seen in British Columbia
so quebecers have an opportunity before
them
they will be able to avoid billing
people for medically
necessary care and diagnoses
this means they will be able to get that
money back over the next two years
following announcements
about addressing Private health care
you've made your NDP Partners happy is
the timing not a touch suspicious
this is a this timing is a legal
requirement
every March towards the end of fiscal
there is a legal obligation placed on
the government of Canada to inform
provinces and territories
about health care transfer deductions
linked to Canadians paying for medically
necessary care
it's not that we chose this moment it's
that it's the same
date roughly every year
because that's when provinces receive
their transfers
the good news is that provinces and
territories have two years
to recoup these deductions
online if you have a question please
raise your virtual hand we will start
with my colleague Mia rapson
yes good morning
um I'm wondering administrative Khloe if
you would be able to clarify what you
intend to tell the provinces about
private fees for these virtual visits
um and maybe some private surgical
clinics
um do you have a a sense of what you
intend if there is any time when virtual
well thank you we all have different
roles in Canada when it comes to
protecting your health would have a fee
for service you intend to rule it out
entirely
so I I think I uh I know to the entire
question thank you for that question now
I was going to say that we all have
different roles but the same
responsibility to make sure that people
receive services not on the basis of
their ability to pay but on the basis of
their medical needs now this is done in
a context in which health ministers
across provinces and territories find it
both great and challenging to see the
significant uh Improvement in the
technology that the health workers can
use and in the way in which we can
eradicate reallocate health workers
across different Health settings now the
the great news is as we've mentioned
earlier virtual care data access nurse
the improved
um and work and and input of nurse
practitioners and physician assistants
this is all very good news for Canadians
patients and workers however my
colleagues Health ministers find find it
very difficult to individually fight
against the risk that this may lead to
billing for medically necessary Health
Care Services now each of my colleague
individually it finds it more difficult
to fight against the risk of private
funding for medically necessary Health
Services when do you do this when they
do this in isolation that's why when we
worked collectively when we recognized
that these challenges are Canadian
challenges it's easier for individual
provinces and territories to then act
and fight against this tendency for this
technology and this these improvements
and in workplace arrangement to lead to
a privatization of funding for the
Health Care system so working together I
believe we can all better address those
challenges and ensure that in Canada for
the years to come despite the changes
that we'll see in technology and
delivery of healthcare we will make sure
that Canadians get access to free
medical medically necessary Health Care
Services
thank you and I guess I'm just still
trying to clarify do you believe that
there should be no fees or service
charged for virtual care at all or is
there space for some charges within that
uh that sector there should be no fees
for medically necessary Health Care
Services wherever people may live in
this country
is there another question online please
raise your hand
I don't know if uh anyone else in the
room wants to ask a follow-up question
we could maybe do one more turn
uh
yes just coming back to my colleague's
question
and your your partnership with the NDP
and the announcement of the new
interpretation letter
to what extent is this letter linked to
NDP criticism
it is more to do with criticism from
Canadians throughout the country
Canadians are happy about recent
Innovations and that is the right term
in
in healthcare delivery and ways to let
health care workers protect Canadians
but
boss
Healthcare free healthcare needs to be
protected and what we are seeing
is that new working environments and new
technologies
are changing practices sometimes for the
better
especially in remote and Rural regions
we know that virtual Healthcare
will play a greater role in coming years
to provide Health Care to people in
remote rural areas at the same time
we do not want to
penalize people
because some people will need to pay for
health care services as they will be
provided virtually and that would be a
source of inequity
it would discriminate against people who
do not have
the resources to pay for ritual Health
Care
some people might not be able to access
health care at all
I do understand that there is criticism
from certain members of the House of
Commons but this is something that
should concern all Canadians and all uh
ministers at all levels of government
some provinces like British Columbia
have already taken significant steps
to try to address these issues
I'd like to give the floor to someone
else I believe David is another question
Dr Tam
um just what's your recommendation I'm
asking at this point in the pandemic
well we know that layers of protection
when
um done consistently together can reduce
uh transmission and spreads as I said in
my update we're a relatively steady
state now in terms of cases
hospitalizations and quite low levels of
icus and death which it puts us in a
relatively good position however
kovid is still very prevalent and so you
can look at Wastewater surveillance you
can look at the other tests and over 3
000 I think people are still in the
hospital
um each day as uh with with a testing
positive for covid
which means that
um you know I think depending on your
risk factors and personal circumstances
in the context of which you
um
um gathering for example
um it's still recommended that you take
precautions
and the nasty recommendation on booster
doses for the highest risk those will
continue then to help keep the
um spread of infection more manageable I
I certainly expect as we move into the
spring and summer months and and
certainly in the outdoors people should
enjoy you know doing much more and may
not need to mask under those
circumstances but
I certainly think that people should
be very well tolerating people who want
to wear a mask because you don't know
the circumstances behind each
individual's
situation so I don't think there's many
circumstances in this country at
different levels of government where
masking is
mandatory but I think is still
recommended
well
concluded with another colleague from
Michelle
I have a question about
consultations in Virtual Healthcare
my understanding is you do not want
Canadians to have to pay out of pocket
for virtual care but
yeah are you uh against these Services
altogether because they could only
benefit to certain portions of the
population
what I should have said earlier is
what I should have clarified
is that
virtual Healthcare Telehealth
has uh has grown a great deal
uh before covid roughly three percent of
Health Care was provided virtually now
it's roughly uh 18 of Health Care
it will continue to grow and it is a
good thing for to improve efficiency and
effectiveness
not all Health Care can be provided
virtually but some Health Care can
effectively be provided online
this reduces uh
costs for patients in terms of time some
people cannot travel to a clinic so
there's all sorts of advantages both for
patients
and healthcare workers
as I have noted virtual Healthcare has
grown from representing three to
eighteen percent of Health Care and it
will continue to expand in the coming
years having said that
this is new technology
and we are in Uncharted Territory
private interests are playing a role and
this could
lead to
overbilling
for
medically necessary care
I say use this racing because there is
some health care that is not medically
necessary
and a payment could be accepted for in
those cases
my priority is to make sure that
Canadians are not paying for medically
necessary Health Care virtually or in
person
this concludes our press conference
thank you have a good day